it's a pleasure to confer Rafi
talk about shares everybody can hear me
yes oh yes it's very nice to be here
thanks a lot for invitation
I think the first stock I ever gave was
in one of these outbursts versus color
combs
it was a 20-minute talk so he's good to
me it's good to be back here yes so the
talk I'm going to give is a joint work
with Alex Kane and Howie Mazur
and we want to talk about tech my space
but before I get there so we're going to
talk about the course geometry of the
type of space so let me start you what
that means
so the the objects that you study harder
here medaka spaces and the objects are
called the same if they're quasi ISO
metric to metric space are quasi
symmetric if there is a map between them
right so the quasi odometry is a map
from X to Y where it doesn't change
distances by so much all right so it's
coarsely on two and doesn't change the
way so much so let me tell you what that
little symbol mean since I'm gonna use
it a few more times
so since I'm doing horse geometry things
are equal and I want to call them equal
so I want to like emphasize that that's
why I'm using that symbol but if I say a
is equal to B that means they're equal
up to a multiplicative and an additive
error right so the constants C and K are
uniform so in this particular case for
example I have a map F so I don't know
what can see are but they don't depend
on x and y that's what I mean they're a
uniform that could be pretty large but
they don't depend on x and y so as long
as two quantities are the same up to a
multiple even I've ever I think of them
as being basically the same and the
definition of quasi is AMA three is
basic definition by isometry the map
which preserves the distance up to this
notion of being the same and you want to
be coarsely onto which means every point
has a point every point Y has a point in
X which maps nearby nearby not exactly
on to it but but near back
so this is the this is course geometry
we look at metric spaces up to being
quasi isometric right so why would you
do such a thing so I think that this
business is started by you know trying
to I mean you're trying to lose geometry
and then so there's a quote from felix
klein which says if you understand the
metric space you should understand the
symmetries and this has actually been
very popular and very you know this is
such a good idea that it's actually it
has turned around a little bit so these
days if you want to understand a group
you want it to be a symmetric group of
some somatic space so this is how you
understand the group so you want if you
have a group you want some space that
this group acts on and the most natural
place that the group acts on is itself
you can make a group into a metric space
easily by choosing a generating set so
this is fine joining financial aid
groups and you use a word metric so the
more basic take the group into the
metric space and then the group acts on
there itself by left translation so so
that's just easy enough the the problem
with that is that if you pick different
joining sets a and B for the same group
then they define different metrics on
this space but the two two norms the
word lengths a and B are equal with this
definition of equal we have which means
they're equal up to additive and what we
do error therefore the metrics they
define on the group G or their quasi I
is the metric so they are the same in
this notion of course geometry you're
talking about right so if you want to
look at the action of G on itself then
you have to just choose which one of
these you want or maybe you don't choose
and just call them all the same right so
then therefore that's why you need the
definition of things being quasi
isometric so the most naturally I think
they appear they appear here right so so
right I mean that kind of the field
you start by work of Gromov and he
proposed in his ICM talk to classify all
groups up to cause the isometry I mean
it's a self you know
there's not an approachable program at
the moment but in lots of cases there
has been lots of progress and every time
you know people have done something
there's lots of new math has been
developed so it's kind of like this is a
motivation for partly motivation for
what we're doing so basically if you
have a group G and it acts on some space
X discretely unco compactly then G is
with this word metric is cos the
isometric to the X which means the
associate to every group we actually
have a quasi ice-o-matic class of metric
spaces right so if the classify groups
at equality isometry is a classifying
this metric is based of the quasi
geometry and then if you have two groups
which are quasi mean to each other then
since every group G acts on itself and G
is causing it to H then G also acts on
hy cause you're a Samba trees so now I
have this metric space X which I
associated to this group G and all the
other groups which are quasi symmetric
to my group are acting quasi
symmetrically on this space so I want to
know who else acts quasi automatically
on this space or basically what are the
quasi isometries of this this new space
so so for this reason you define the
notion of the quasi eyes dhamma tree
group right so given a metric space you
want to understand all the quasi
isometries of this so it's got a very
natural object because I mean EPO to
enforce geometry is like computing the
isometric loop is a group of symmetries
of some space so note that the F and G
there are two different causes Amira's
are called the same right if they're the
same in this sense like they move every
point so the distance between f of X and
G of X I write equal to zero this is
basically a fancy everything that there
are the distance is bounded I write it
this way to kind of emphasize you know
this notion of equality right so this is
basically saying f of X equals to G of X
up to the errors that other type that we
are talking about right so so you
identify two different quasi anomalies
if the abundance is apart and then then
you can compose them and to quasi
symmetries the composition is also quasi
isometry
so this is a group and if you have a
group G now which has some attic space
attached to it
maybe itself and it's quasi somatic to a
group H then there is a map from H to
the quasi eyes on the group of G right
because H acts on itself so which means
Xin Jie why cause I don't agree so
there's a map from here so to understand
this and which groups are coordinated to
G you can only have to compute this this
group first and also this is a quasi
isometric invariant to two spaces which
are quasi symmetric they have the same
group so you have computed yourself and
invariant also ok so this is my I guess
motivation for doing course geometry
what are the good examples so the
beginning the devil you know easy
examples are well not easy examples the
first things you might want to start
thinking about our symmetrical spaces
and in fact they have been studied quite
extensively the it's good to start with
the you know spaces like RN or HN
because this is faces are have really
really terrible really bad quasi eyes
article I mean like to understand this
sometimes the problem could be
complicated it's good to look at r2 if
you have a r2 a quasi motive or two
could you know maybe spiral geodesics
around in a really horrible way really
you don't have any good control of what
the quasi matter more to looks like also
in h h2 or hn if you have even though
you have hyperbola city and you know the
jews if they are stable and you feel
like there you have some control you you
really don't if you have quasi amma tree
of h and to itself it you know because
you know euclidean models at least you
did this is kind of shrink exponential
as you go to the boundary it extends to
conform up on a boundary but quasi
confirm all homeomorphisms all extend to
cause yama - I'm saying if something
distance bounded from identity it
extends to the conform up to the
boundary but if you have something quasi
conformal from SN to SN x tends to cause
the eyes on T so this is a good class of
quasi me to think about any quasi
conformed up on the boundary extends to
across the eyes amma tree
so there are a lot more causing
confirming upstander confirm laughs like
one of them is a finite dimensional
object is the infinite dimension object
so the this is spaces could be really
really large space of quasi isometries
of space could be pretty out of control
very easily and in the special cases
where the well if you understood all
cause I can't follow maps to be done
right there anyway did so that's that's
right but well I also the map I don't
think it's on too so there is even more
of these than they cause it comes from
Oh guys I know it they may be on in this
case is an actually don't yeah that's
right so anyway so I call a metric space
rigid if it's cause the isometry group
is the same as its isometry so looking
at this examples you might think this
never happens but it but it does happen
it does happen so the in fact the
symmetric spaces there are lots of
examples the other rank one submitting
spaces which is the the quaternary onic
hyperbolic plane and the Cayley plane
the these guys are in fact rigid so the
the first three of them are also rank
one so the other guys are all rigid and
the higher rank you do serve all
symmetric spaces are also rigid and if
you're not really visible then you're
going to have our ends in it and so on
so you're not but I'll say some more
about what else can you say what
reducible is in a second so ok so
besides these three examples which look
really really really horrible the other
Civic spaces actually are all rigid the
quasi boo-boos understand this is this
is a lot of work to prove this stuff
that this is this is a pork upon su and
this is a coin on leap and an
independent later by a skin and Farb
right so about the irreducible guys so
if you have a let's do an easy example
because since we talked about h2 a
little bit or a
if you have a product of two h2s the
quasi is AMA three you might see this is
a really bad space because each of these
h2s are not rigid they can just move
them around really horribly and then the
product has all these our tools and our
tools are also not rigid you can move
them around in a pretty horrible way so
you expect to have no control whatsoever
on a quasi isometry of an object like
this but in fact you do and what you can
say is that the quasi is dama tree
distinguishes the hyperbolic direction
from a non hyperbolic direction so yes
if you have a map from H to cross H 2 2
itself then it factors to a product of
v1 times v2 which each VI is a quasi
geometry from h2 to itself so you can
move there to that bad as you want and
the other lectures but as you want but
you have to preserve the product
structure right so yes this is also
what's proven by kleiner and liebe and
they actually generalize this to all
symmetric spaces except you have to
worry about the h2s again and are our
tools but otherwise you can always a
split and then since each of those
factors are rigid you have lots of
utilities for most of us America spaces
right so so you have so as we see there
there are some controls in some cases ok
so I think this is the history of as
much as I want to do this day's much
more I mean in fact we're gonna have
other talk about rigidity which is a
slightly different context of rigidity
although it's quite quite related but
yes so today I want to talk about the
ocular space it's our force basically so
what is the techno space talk my space
is a space of marked Riemann surfaces
homeomorphic to a surface s or maybe the
mark hyperbolic surfaces because there's
a uniformization so this is a very nice
space it's a finite dimensional space it
has a dimension 3 G minus 3 plus P if
you have genus G with punctures
and there is a metric and this is space
call it hyper metric which is basically
said this is this is a naturally a
complex manifold this is actually the
Kobayashi metric so that's a metric
which makes the Schwarz lemma to still
be true so you have maps from h2 to your
Tyco on myspace you wanted to be
distance decreasing holomorphic maps
from h2 to techno space or distance
decreasing so this is called the
tricolour techno metric and then there
is a I mean in many ways the tag my
space is analogous to a symmetric space
at least the way it's been studied it's
been like that through this analogy and
this is kind of a you know I can talk
about this for for too long but I mean
you have lattices in Tunica spaces and
the tag my space also has something like
that the mapping class group acts on it
and the coefficient is finite volume
also them back to after you've quotient
the tycoon's by swapping class cubic a
the moduli space the moduli space is not
like a symmetric space in fact it's
totally unsymmetric so what does that
mean the what that means is that if you
break it into little pieces and look at
each piece you can tell from the piece
we're in a modular space this comes from
no piece of moduli spaces like any other
piece of it so yes our friend Rodrigo
here promised to demonstrate this later
for people there is a game called
geoguessr the if you go to the geoguessr
comm they sends you to some random place
on earth and you can walk around a
Google map all right then you don't know
where you are
and you're supposed to guess where you
are based it's not just what you see
around you and and if you see you know
like if I played I don't do so well but
if Rodrigo plays if he can usually get
where he is within making a few minutes
like really cool so it's amazing
actually how much information there is
just from like yeah the middle of
nowhere like from like little signs and
cars are driving by and so on so yes I
mean they give you a middle of ocean
you're like a symmetrical space because
you look around you you have no idea
where in the ocean you are but if you're
playing geoguessr it sends you even I
mean man most likely you know exactly
where you are but just looking around a
little bit so that's what the
talking with spaces like it's totally
totally unsymmetric but so you might say
this is Nikki not like a symmetric space
in any way but but it has it this SL to
our action it says well I said or GMT or
axon is a cotangent space so there is no
action on the space itself but at the
level of cotangent space there is an
action there is a very nice group action
and then you know you can do dynamics
and so on so that's also has been a big
source of analogy to the asymmetrical
space right so if it is like a symmetric
space we want to understand if it's
rigid right so that's a that's all
question and in fact the theorem is
except for the two cases the four times
punctured the sphere and the once
punctured torus the cause the isometry
group of the Tycho space is equal to its
article okay so a few little things the
isometric loop is basically the mapping
class group as I mentioned before the
there are some few cases the two cases
which are we just mentioned in the case
of one puncture torus and for
temperature sphere the tracking space is
basically the hyperbolic plane so it has
a larger geometry group not coming from
the home of a surface or anything like
that and in the case of the twice
punctured Taurus you have this extra
isometry which comes from the five times
punctuated sphere I mean you can take a
double cover right take a quotient by it
you know of a genus one with two
punctured surface and you get a [ __ ]
bunch of sphere and you can rotate that
and that's also induces an isometry so
that's why I write it like that but
basically this is equal to the mapping
class group right so so that's the
that's the theorem for today I mean this
is a I mean in some sense direct analogy
or like the next step natural step after
the proof of I mean the mapping class
group so there's been a you know this
has been on the news and people have
talked about this many times so the
mapping class group is also known to be
rigid again except for the exceptions so
this is the work of a personal kleiner
Minsky Moser and independently or so how
much
so and this comes also from the analogy
to the symmetrical spaces so if you are
acting compact in a symmetrical space of
course your quasi is I'm going to so
there's nothing to say but if you're if
you're non-uniform that is you can also
ask you about the agility in this case
their rigidity has a slightly different
meaning it just means the map from the
compensator into the quasi geometry
group is on - I'm for the rank one
lattices for ya for non uniform lattices
also the rigid is known so that's the
work of which Schwartz for rank one and
some high rank and in general or high
rank by Alex esque right so yeah I mean
so there's the analogous question so the
mapping has computed also have been
proven in a symmetrical space so you're
doing the other side so so why am i why
am I doing this
the I get asked that a lot actually
there so he decided to have a slight
explaining it so yes as I was explaining
the last you know 20 minutes it's
analogy with the symmetrical spaces is
one big motivation the the second thing
is right so I mean there has been lots
of tools developed especially the care
of complex the distance formulas
you understand the Jude I think you
understand quasi genetics I'll talk
about some of this stuff so you have
devolve all these tools and we kind of
like reach a point that we understand
the course geometry of tacular space
it's kind of hard to say that in a
sentence I understand the course
geometry of technologies but if you
prove the rigidity so this is actually a
code from Aladdin I don't know if I'm
paraphrasing or not is that you know if
if you can compute the cause I want to
have a space you kind of showed
everybody that you understand this the
space
so so I mean you know we kind of
understood this a space so I wanted to
tell everybody that I you know let me do
so this is this is kind of like that so
I mean I can compute it you know all the
quasi isometries but there is maybe
another motivation and which is the
proof of the rigidity of the mapping
class group was very different from our
prefer which it have tagged myspace they
use the asymptotic cone which has been
very popular and in fact it's been used
to prove most of the religious
statements about the symmetrical spaces
so but that's not the only way only
thing you can do and in fact high
chronic space is not so well I mean it's
not immediately suited for that because
you want to like to improve rigidity
after mapping class group you want to
see what are the flats are and maybe
distinguish some flats from the other
flats the flats are quasi I simply
embeddings of like high dimensional or
ends into your space and for tech my
space star no causing the embeddings of
high dimensional ions into your twice my
space like for for hiding after
dimensions even though they're like
pieces of it which look flat there are
no you know embeddings of the whole are
ends into into your space in fact I
think Brian voltage proved that finally
the that in some dimensions there are no
maps for more and into your space so you
know they knew the other approach which
exists already is kind of like weed is a
local approach that we just look at the
big balls inside of your space and try
to examine that you don't have to go to
a silicon you don't have to have
infinite things just having look at the
large balls in your space that has
enough information which tell you like
whatever you are or what's what's going
on so we could have developed that which
has actually existed in the literature a
little bit more and then this is kind of
wish to showcase the powers of this
local arguments as well right so let me
just say the people are trying to prove
eg attack my space using the oscillating
cone it may work as far as I know I'm
not saying that there is no way to do
that there so Bryant posted the paper
and he proves that the thick part of the
TaqMan space goes to a thick part on any
quasi geometry and then you are
something nearly away from the chromatic
part you have some bounds and so on
so what so other people are working on
this but that'sthat's how far they can
go
I mean so I'm gonna get into the the
proof slowly so if there are no comments
so let me tell you what what use what
tools do we use yes so in fact so you
have the techno space it has a
decomposition to the take part and the T
part so maybe I'll talk about that a
little bit right so you're talking with
space you can draw it kind of like a
circle as usual I mean if I have a
surface it kind of looks like that if it
has a short curve then I would say this
surface is thin and if it doesn't have
any short curve so there's a you know
fixed lower bound on the length of all
possible short curves then I call the
surface stick and so do you divide the
tacular space right somehow to the time
to learn tick all right and then the way
this looks like at least in the case of
h2 which I can actually draw the picture
the pin parts so for the case of h2 your
your punctured torus or just a torus and
only one curve can be short at a at a
given time and the parts of the h2 which
are associated with this particular
curve being short or Horrible's and they
kind of live like that you know any
rational point you have a nice horrible
so this is the thin part and the thick
part is everything else okay so if you
have a thin part you have a product
region which are actually write down
basically we can do things here and here
separately so the metric you have here
is like a soup metric and the Judah is
that you have a take a product structure
so the geodesics in the product
structure are not stable since I have
the word is stable up there
maybe I should just say what that means
so stability means I called you like a
stable basically if it looks like it's
living inside of a hyperbolic space so
the exact thing is that if you have a
ball which is disjoint from this and
kind of far away no matter how Boyle how
how large the ball is the shadow of this
ball along this geodesic is bounded then
I call this joseki stable right so the
theorem here is that if you haven't you
dezik which is stays in a thick part so
this is kind of a schematic picture but
I should just you know imagine music
which is stays companion thick part and
there exist a lot of those then these
guys are stable so these guys look like
they live inside of hyperbolic space so
thick part a quiz this is hyperbolic
this is the theorem of Biscay that
exactly statement so and being stable
the property that is preserved under the
quasi isometry so if I have a do dezik
and projections are bounded and I take
an image of this it has still the same
property and since the J's which go in
the teen part are not stable and the
ones which is stay in the thick part are
stable this distinguishes the stable and
the tikkun team part so you immediately
get that the thick part of attack my
space is actually preserved on the quasi
assembly so this is a you know just from
from here is the theorem it's basically
very quick so that's the stern or the
first step of the proof although brian's
proof is different so he use a spec home
to prove this but this just follows from
Yeager's ok so so there really the hard
part is there is the thin part and it's
like when you have lots of different
curves that are short and maybe their
lengths of these short curves are very
different so it's kind of harder to
control what's going on so especially
since you have a product structure so
you have a product structure
let's say I have r2 with a soup metric
or any other metric right so then this
is a geodesic and this is also geodesic
so the juice extent and they're going
forwards oxygen you have lots of
different uses going like that and you
really don't have any control of what
the what did you do six to so if I have
a two dezik and I pass it forward now by
quasi isometry a priority could do some
horrible spoiling thing inside of that
so what we do is we do a course
differentiation so I'm going to talk
about this in in a bit more so I'm not
gonna talk about so much now but
basically gets you a control over images
of quaza to DES X and this has been used
already by asking patient white when
they talked about the rigidity of the
salt geometry okay and then so using
that we in the earlier work with asking
maze and how amazed there we kind of
give a description local description of
flats inside of talked new space so and
then we also have a local version of
this fitting here remember the speeding
theorem yes this guy so you have a I
mean you know if you have products then
you can split things and we don't have
products but we have local products big
balls [ __ ] look like products so we
need local version of a spinning theorem
so basically our goal is to do
everything locally I never you know take
a simpatico nor look at the whole space
at the same time okay sorry for all the
back-and-forth yeah so these are all
tools so I'll just go over them kind of
more more slowly the I guess testability
I talked about already
okay so course differentiation yeah so
the notion of quality you think is kind
of too loose you want to make it a
slightly tighter so you define this
notion of a efficient path the efficient
paths are supposed to be the course
notions of straight lines so what is a
straight line if you have
metrical space you have triangle
inequality but if you have three points
on a straight line you can tell they're
on a straight line or two anyway if they
have a reverse triangle inequality right
if the sum of the two edges is also less
than equal to the the big edge so we
want to make that into a definition so
if you have a path we say it's epsilon
efficient if it has reverse trying an
equality so pick bunch of points in it
right it's that this is the sum of the
distances along this points is less than
the sum of this is the end point
possibly near small linear error and if
epsilon is the smallest come not visible
so I make my life at the moment a bit
more coarser than before so before I had
additive errors and now I want to have a
small linear errors as just being right
it's small so yes I mean you should
think of this as a straight line up to a
lower order right up the door board so
these paths happen to be a bit nicer
except that they are not in a soup
metric so if I have this or two with a
soup metric this palette I drew here not
only the quality liquid is still
efficient because the distance from here
to here is the same as this from here to
here so I can't really see what I'm
doing going up here these guys I hate
they're really bad because they
basically want to go from here to here
in one product vector but they're
backtracking in the other one if I look
at the position to this factor they go
up and they come down this is called
backtracking
so I don't like that and I don't want my
efficient paths to do that
so I have to change the meta contact no
space from this from a soup metric into
a l1 metric so what does that mean I
mean basically every time I have a
product region I want to like add up the
both factors but I want to do this
globally so this is kind of hard but
thankfully it's been done by by best we
know brahmic and fujiwara they they have
this embedding of a mapping class group
into product of finitely many hyperbolic
spaces and the same construction works
to embed the techno space into product
of finding many high working spaces and
then we use an embedding and put a l1
metric on there
on the image and we pull this back to
get a metric for track
so then they have some control over
preferred paths so if you had this
preferred path then you would know that
the their per dollar also if you have
efficient paths then there are also
preferred paths and preferred paths are
the ones which don't do this
backtracking business their projection
to the care of complex is a quasi Judaic
stay in every sub surface they just go
forward they don't do anything more
complicated okay so but where would
prefer pads come from and you have a
quasi I geometry
how would you end up with preferred
paths so this is the the magic of course
differentiation this is an analog of a
Rademacher theorem which is if you have
a Lipschitz map from RN to RM then it's
differentiable almost everywhere so what
is a what is differentiable mean
differentiable means if I pick a
straight line it goes basically to a
straight line doesn't Bend like that
goes to a straight line all right up to
a degree one if you ignore the Lord
lower terms so that's the definition you
want to emulate so for us to be
differentiable coarse differentiable
means straight lines go to straight
lines and the notion of straight lines
is now this efficient paths Absalon
efficient paths so we call a map
efficient if it sends every straight
line into an efficient path right so
that's kind of what we want and the
theorem says that we can find these all
the time there is no problem there's no
if you have any quasi isometry so the
same way that if you have any Lipschitz
map it's and you don't know anything
about it at all it's you have derivative
everywhere so that's kind of equally
magical is this thing that if you have a
course Lipschitz map so quasi Lipschitz
map then it's a course in differential
almost everywhere so the way it means is
that so it means that I can find a scale
or that if I subdivide my box into some
boxes of size R so I have this here a
huge box and I I can find a scale and I
pick a net of points in that scale and I
look at all the boxes with the corners
in that net and the cap size are
then most of these guys in fact for any
number theta 1 minus theta of those
boxes are efficient democracy - these
boxes are efficient here you would say
like it's differentiable here or
differentiable here and I'm saying it's
differentiable almost everywhere right
it's it's kind of a weird thing I mean
you if you think about it I mean a
geodesic could go into some horrible
weekly thing this is this is what
qualities could look like and you're
wondering you know how is anything like
that works here I mean you know there
are always bends and so on happening but
the thing is if I if I divide this to
the correct scales somehow I can do it
so most of these guys they look pretty
straight because if they're if being
efficient failed at every single level
they would accumulate and we'll get a
contradiction for being a quasi
Lipschitz basically the same proof of
their armor his theorem it's like if you
if you recall at every little scale then
you are not really Lipschitz that's
that's kind of very inefficient so at
some scale you have to be straight so
you have to be differentiable
ok so this is a this is kind of the
first this is the first step from the
still a previous previous paper and then
it so we use this to to classify the the
flats locally so let me tell you a
little bit about that as I promised so
this is the product region theorem of of
your ear if you have a multi curve gamma
then you can look at the important ahmed
space where these curves are short like
yeah maybe I need to
so maybe this curve is short and this
curve is shorter together this is alpha
1 or alpha and beta so the gamma is
alpha and beta and then G gamma is all
surfaces with these two exact curves
alpha and beta are short so then gamma
divides my surface into a bunch of sub
surfaces namely this punctured genus 2
surface here this 3 times punctured
units to surface here but also I want to
think of this annual I here as
complementary components because they
are disjoint from from the care right
and the talkin specific analysis is
basically H 2 because it has either
twisting or lengt and what I'm saying is
that you have a product of type my
spaces here which is talkin so this is
space this is face and these two annual
I and locally the geometry of Technol
space is like a product of these two
spaces right so so this is the object
this is the origin theorem and then the
we say a point here well maybe I went
too far
the point here is has a maximal rank if
the number of packages is maximum
possible so for example this is not
maximal rank because I could maybe
potentially make this curve also short
is that right yeah so then I would have
a genus one with the two function and I
can make this curve also short and then
I would have 1 2 3 4 5 then there's one
more like it probably do
yeah I mean I kind of set myself up for
something complicated but this is not so
good I don't know yeah can I crash yeah
why not that was that was fine right so
anyway so there are a bunch of cars I
can make shirt but I want to like yes
maybe I'll draw on your picture so you
are of maximal rank if every component
you have is either punctured tourists
annulus like that four times punctured
sphere like that you have one two three
and four or a hundred animals over here
so this is a point of maximal rank
because the number of four times Pontius
we have these spheres that have no type
no spaces so there are just points but
every four ten punches here or annulus I
pick I get an actual factor which is our
Matic to h2 so this is the Vista maximum
number I can get so what how are you
saying that if I if I add one more curve
here then I'm gonna divide this four
times punches sphere into two three nine
matches sphere each of them have only
one point is that a common space but I
have added another factor here which is
the twisting and length annulus
so there are many different
configurations which could give me the
maximum rank is not when all the curves
are short at the same time yeah so
something like that is still the maximal
rank so the basically the image has the
most number of factors it could possibly
have so an annulus or one step'
punctured tourist or four times
conscious fear so I call this guy's
maximal rank so I I already know the
thick part has gone to take part so my
next step is to prove that the maximal
rank the points of this type are also
preserved they go to the points of
maximal rank and for that we need this
little statement which we need to
understand the flat the maximal the
emotional flat which is the dimension
exactly equal to the maximal rank we
have to understand them locally and this
was also in the previous work which says
that the any flat you have
locally looks like product a bunch of
geodesics in each of these guys so if I
have a lot of factories I have taken a
space of each of these guys and I can
pick it each of them is a copy of h2 and
I can pick music in each one of them
just excitement GW and the product of
these two does X will give me a flat and
all flats locally cannot look like them
that's right that's right
so by flat right that's a very good
question so everything we are doing is
low cost so by flat I just mean a very
large ball in our end being mapped quasi
automatically to my space so remember
like all Mike all my theorems have the
condition of there's a large ball which
has some property so everything is some
sense is local very very large but still
still very local ok so let me tell you
kind of quickly how does this prove that
the maximal rank goes to the maximal
rank right so yes so let's say you have
a point X here is who is in a maximal
rank so it means there bunch of curves
which are short and they divide things
to pieces which the complementary color
companies are puncher tourists or for
that matter spheres so this means
there's a very large ball around if the
curves are really short there's a large
ball around it which is everybody here
is also maximal rank but imagine this
point X goes to a point here f of X
which is not maximal rank so for example
it has a genus 2 with one boundary here
somewhere and there may be some other
things we don't know but it has one
piece which is not the lowest possible
complexity and it's still pretty thick
right so then I can pick a Jew's aquick
and it stays in this component so
Pikachu Isaac geni passing through this
point a very very large geodesic and I
look at the end points of this and I
find points here y&z which are mapped
into these end points so if this ball
was big enough this point y&z are still
in the maximum rank and in fact I can
connect these two guys by Judas you can
look at the product of those Joseph so
there's this maximal box here which sits
in here call
metrically this is a maximal dimensional
box right and this box now has to map
over here and his endpoints are being
mapped to the end points of this Judah's
right
so then what then I do course
differentiation which means I can divide
this box into sub boxes of some
particular scale so that basically all
of them are efficient every single one
of them is efficient okay so this guy
maybe maps over here and then I want to
say if I have an efficient box here of
maximal dimension it cannot make
progress along this geodesic its
projection to this geodesic has to be
uniformly bounded and this is because if
it wasn't uniformly bounded if it was
actually making progress it would really
have to be close to this and in fact it
has to like if I pick a point from here
and point from here and they fail
trouble they have to come close by and
in fact all of the points near by this
point and all the points near by this
point have to come close by which means
like a smaller sub box here actually
Maps completely near this judeth like
their position in this particular sub
surface is near that geodesic but then
this would be a contradiction because
then even a smaller sub box in here has
to be standard has to have this exact
shape and if you are near this two days
that you cannot have that shape if
you're moving in maximal number of
directions at the same time then you are
not staying in a big part of a bigger
cell surface so that's that's there's a
little argument here so you pick your
box which is making progress you look at
each sub box which is efficient and
there's a lot of them and then you say
okay this sub box could not have made
progress here because if I did a smaller
sub box would be nearer this guy and the
smaller sub box in that would be
standard and the standard guy cannot be
near a picture as it can a sub surface
which means none of these guys which are
efficient make progress but the ones
which are not efficient they could make
progress but there's not so many of them
and you have to make a lot of progress
and you can't do that so most of them
are not efficient so you really need
differentiability almost everywhere to
make this argument work right but anyway
so this is the this is the argument and
it proves that the points which are of
maximal rank are also preserved then
what so now I have to study these points
of maximal rank so you need somehow keep
track of the factors and so on so you
need a local version of the splitting
theorem so this is kind of long but it's
basically the same as before if you have
a map from a very big box or big ball in
inside of the apply to a choose into
part of H dues so before we had maths
from PI over 2 to PI which to s but we
can now do this locally it's just a big
ball in it then is still this factors
into product a bunch of free eyes but
you have to restrict yourself to a
smaller ball and the range of smaller
ball is smaller than this but maybe not
so much as smaller so again this means
up to a multiplicative an additive error
well I write bigger right which means is
bigger optimal error which means is
bigger than 1 billion tablet - the
trillion awesome yeah but so that's what
that see mostly it's bigger so it's no
not much smaller than yeah but yeah
typically much much smaller right and
then the so the restriction to to this
ball factors like that and then I say
this is equal or should have actually
read this this is equal in the sense
that we just talked about means the
difference between these two maps is
additive not actually equal okay so so
you prove you prove that
and then so you're examining the maximal
rank and you have to be able to tell the
difference between the points of this
type where there are some thick
components but they're just H two
components the punctured torus or four
patches sphere and the points which are
in fact
let's see if you can draw a picture kind
of like that where the set of short
curves actually gives you a panas
decomposition so these are the shortcuts
so I want to deposit with these two guys
so let me define that set I define a
maximal cusp to be the set of points
where there is a whole set of plastic
compositions P where all the curves are
short and in fact the lengths of these
shortcuts are almost the same and by
almost the same I mean the ratio of the
log of the lengths is somehow bounded
this is a very coarse version of being
the same
it's basically means that this is where
thick part is basically the same up to a
uniform multiplicative error there are
equally far away from coming back to the
thick part because you can change the
length exponentially fast that's why I
take the take the log here so this is a
little like a cone inside of your
product region and so we want to say
that this set by itself is also
preserved there's a point where there
are lots of shortcuts and they have the
same amount of length and the reason is
because I can give a geometric
description of this set and by jod I
mean something which is preserve under
quasi isometry so what is such a
description let's see what this points
are first of all during a maximal rank
so that's very given but so is the other
one
second of all the distance I get to the
box to a lower rank I can compute its
sum number D so that this one has to be
preserve up to some some amount but the
other thing is if I am here then I can
change the length of this curve and go
to someplace where there's a twice
punctured torus which is thick and
that's a lower range right so there's
the one factor geodesic to a lower rank
from these points to a point like that
but from the points that maximal cuts
there is no one factor Judaic there are
two have to be two factorials and this
one factor thing I can talk about
because I have this local splitting so I
know what factors are and in fact I can
do analytic continuation and glue them
together and I can have even longer one
factors and I know what they are but
there is some errors in it but as long
as these guys are basically equal length
that's much bigger than the error so
can actually tell this apart so the
difference between these two guys is
there is a one factor Joy's X going to
the lower rank here but there is no one
factor Joseph here going to a lower rank
right so so the maximal maximal cusps
also have to be preserved so now what
now we have this space tau T ADA which
was the maximum cusp up to some number
ADA but this is faces disconnected if I
have some pasta composition which is
really really short and some other pans
accomplished just short maybe this one
there is no way to go from one to the
other one without coming out of this
maximum cost so I have a disconnected
set which I'm sending it which is
preserved so my map is the permutation
on this disconnected set and in fact
since it preserves distances it has to
send nearby guys to nearby guys so each
of these guys is their hands the
composition so it's a maximal cell in
the in a care of complex and basically
this nearby guy's going to nearby guys
means the maximal cells would share a
lower dimensional cell they have to go
to maximal cells which share a lower
dimensional self yes okay right so so
that's exactly saying that you induce a
simplicial map on the curve complex
right so the simpler map comes from the
coma Toric's of how you move around the
these connected components of the
maximal cusp okay so and that's how we
get our mapping class every simply show
of autumn orphism of a health complex is
induced by a mapping class so that's not
exactly true except for this load
geniuses but don't worry about that but
that exactly match has a same issue as
the eyes on T group of the track no
space does but let's ignore that for a
second so we have our mapping class and
then we post composer causes Emma to be
the mapping class now we have a quasi
isometry which is sending a thick part
to take part which ID we knew already
and sends the maximal cusps to
themselves to actually to themselves
wait
so there are under nose fixed but still
this is just some one cone here the
points they haven't talked about at all
or the points which a lot of curves are
short
but the lengths of these are really
really different maybe this is one over
a billion and this is one of a much
smaller number so that's that's kind of
the harder part but so that's the only
thing left but it turns out this maximal
cusp or kind of if I change this number
ADA they are basically everything so so
let me tell you how to finish the proof
yes so we pick a number eight a zero you
look at the tag the maximum cost
associated to the ada zero so you pick a
component of that let's say that's C C
so C an F of C we already know so the
maximal customers to maximal cost and
the maximum cost is a subset of product
of H two s and F of C is also subset of
H two s so this is means you have a map
from a sub sub point of H 2004 H two is
so that's very good and they have this
local is splitting theorem so locally
things is split then we can do an
article continuation and glue these
local screw things and get a global
splitting which the error instead of
being additive is now a small
multiplicative but that's okay and then
we also know that the F received to the
peak part is identity because so why do
we know that if you have a surface in
the thick part it has lots of boundary
length curves and in fact they overlap
and intersect and so on but I'm knowing
the names of the curves that are banded
length in the surface tells you where
the surface is often additive error so
if I want to know where a point in take
part goes I can see which components
have this maximal cost per and nearby
and these are exactly the curves are
bounded language I could make a short
kind of an abundant amount of time so by
just since I know these components
codons are the sets I can like anchor
mice point to these guys and then since
I didn't you know why anchors have to
stay the same length and the composter
fix the points in the thick part also
fix okay so that's how you get that the
thick part is identity so this is that
and you know that your map factors so
you have a map which is but a part of
these guys and each product
is basically so it's better than being a
inner product of H 2 s C is actually in
product of Horrible's there's a subset
of product of a mu CH with other line so
this is the horrible sure things like
that right and the map from C to product
of Horrible's factors sophie is product
of v1 times some VK and each VK is a map
from a horrible to itself and in the
peak part if I automatic part then this
is these points and the map is identity
right since when all the Mattituck point
is not the identity then these three is
restricted to the boundary of the horror
cycle have to be identity
so each VI was going to the boundary of
the whole circle is basically go to
identity and each VI is bounded this as
a is a linear distance from a quasi
isometry okay so but if you are bounded
anything over here you have to basically
be identity over here so this means VI
is basically equal to identity up to a
linear error
but the fee is I need leave an error of
expect every single base point you pick
in here you could pick your base point
over here I'm your arrow is linear and
pick a base point here well error is
linear so this means every signal to C
is equal to identity up to minion error
between every single base point but
linear Arabs I'm saying every single
base point it just means I'll give equal
to identity so I mean so this is this is
how the rigidity in the thin part comes
from basically H 2 is really bad there
are lots of quasi zonas of H 2 which are
really bad and are hard to control but
there are not so many there are no
quality other matters are horrible to
itself which are bad in fact there's a
lot of control and there are no H twos
in a gin in the techno space they are
really particle horrible and the
boundary of these guys are in the thick
part which I can control so I can
control what happens inside of each
other horrible right so so that's the so
that's that step and then the last step
is a kind of a little clever thing so I
have proven that this cone goes to the
you know to some bigger cone maybe I
don't know what happens to it first
but now I did leave more argument and I
proved the image of this cone is
actually close to identity so it Kong
actually goes to itself so now I can
make a cone a little bit bigger because
if the cone goes to itself the nearby
points in the cone they cannot go so far
that much farther away so which means
there is a bigger cone where Aida is
just like some multiple bigger than
either zero which is actually preserved
it goes also to the similar count but
then the bigger corner can argue the
same way to be identity which would
prove even a bigger cone is preserved so
you iterate that infinitely many times
and the union of all these cones is
basically everything because every point
you pick there is some ratio between the
shortcuts and that's the end of the
proof so I'm sorry about thing about the
very end just want to do the whole proof
or thank you for your attention I'll
stop